under a biden administration do you
think that
it's better or worse for free speech
what's your
predictions there or what's your what's
your sense i know that you don't like
making predictions
i think it's worse i think it is worse
so this is the uh
i mean trump had his blind spots on free
speech which we should never be he was
not
very good on press freedom for instance
i think if he if he could have had his
way he would have
quite been quite happy to shut down his
critics and muzzle his critics i don't
think there could be any doubt about
that
i think the risk with biden is that he
you know i mean i remember having a lot
of discussions before the election and
a lot of people who were voting by them
were sort of saying but you know these
fears that he's going to be awoke
person he was voted in because he's the
non-woke candidate right that's why
we don't have we don't have elizabeth
warren
in the white house because because
wokeness doesn't win votes let's face it
you know
uh this is why kamala harris had to drop
out the primaries so early because she
just wasn't popular
um and so you know all
and then and then a lot of people would
say to me you know well that that it's a
it's a false fear but then within two
days
a number of the executive orders are
specifically woke executive orders you
think oh hang on a minute this is a bad
thing
wokeness and and the opposition of
freedom of speech go hand in hand
uh they just do because because as i've
said of this belief in
uh the uh power of language to to form
reality and that's really what it's
about uh so i don't think
firstly also i don't think biden and his
administration
have any appetite to address the
problems of big tech censorship
uh because big tech is on their side at
the moment
you know it's very myopic because if you
go into the
you know they should be thinking long
term here um they don't want to set
these kind of precedence
so there's that uh there's also a
movement as you know america to have the
the first amendment changed amend the
amendment so that um
hate speech is not protected speech uh
but of course hate speech as a
formulation
is just as i say in the book it's a kind
of fudge
uh for to to deal with uh or to suggest
that speech that you don't like
is not subject to constitutional
protection that's all that that is so
um which is why i argue in the book was
to be one of the the arguments i
imagine is going to get me in a bit of
trouble is that i think all hate speech
laws ought to be repealed
and that there is no place for hate
speech laws on any statute books in a
liberal democracy
um and i think uh under biden and his
administration the problem of hate
speech is going to get worse
as it seems to be in this country a
little bit you've got the law commission
pushing
pushing now for further hate speech
regulation when what they should be
doing is dialing
existing legislation back and they're
going the other way the smp
of course in scotland under humza
youssef the justice secretary as far as
i can see is a kind of maniac
who thinks that you should um prosecute
people in their own homes
for things that they say i mean this is
properly authoritarian stuff
like even a lot of people on the left
are like oh hang on a minute this is too
much you know this is
uh it's it's it's scary stuff and um
the problem is we need to i was talking
to a politician about this
the other day we need to find a way for
politicians to be brave enough
just to stand up and say because it
sounds like you're saying i want
everyone to be able to be hateful i want
everyone to say hateful things
and you're not saying that you're
talking about a much bigger picture
about free speech
and about the fact that the state has no
place at deciding what its citizens can
and cannot say
because that way tyranny lies so it's
going to take a brave
politician it's always it always takes a
degree of courage to defend free speech
because what you're doing
is you're defending the rights of
unpleasant people to say unpleasant
things
as as a corollary of what you're doing
inevitably because speech that isn't
controversial doesn't require protection
so it's difficult um and that's why i
emphasize in the book that if you're
defending someone who's saying something
that's utterly reprehensible
you should also make the point just
strategically just make the point that
you don't agree with what they're saying
and you find it reprehensible
be clear because otherwise people will
use it against you they'll do it anyway
by the way
you know i mean like it doesn't matter
what you say because people will just
put words into your mouth that seems to
be the norm now people just
decide what you secretly think you know
you saw this god owen jones tweeted the
other day that he was saying that um the
reason why
gb news is so popular can be explained
because everyone who supports it has
this fear of
is a reactionary who has a fear of
progress so what you've done is you've
just decided what's going on in the
minds
of all these millions of people about a
program that doesn't even exist yet
that you've also just decided what it's
about it's this insane
degree of entitlement i think it's i
think it's
demented i mean the idea that you you
you think you know what's going on in
anyone's heads
is is is you know on the face of it
absurd but to just
casually diagnose millions of people
with your cod psychology
over twitter i can't imagine being that
entitled
that narcissistic for god's sake you
know just before i'd sent tweet i'd be
like
i'd be thinking oh should i should i say
should i be advertising the fact that i
think
i'm better than everyone else and can
decide on their behalf what they're
secretly thinking should i tweet that
or should i have a little bit of [ __ ]
humility well
not everyone has that the thing that i
can't
get out of my head is i i don't meet
people like
owen jones or anybody else i don't meet
a decorating head i don't meet these
sorts of people that say these sorts of
things despite having met an awful lot
of people but newcastle seems to
filter out the maniacs in in quite a
good way no one wants to come this far
yeah i think
i don't know what it is you have your
own kind of maniacs though that's
correct yeah that is very true
um and the thing i always think i always
excuse it away in my own head
by saying it's just the clout because
now
things that are sort of inflammatory and
cause response
they garner momentum and
that this i know that that can't be true
i'm that's the best
faith like potential that their words
can have
is that they're just using them and they
don't believe them because if they
believe them this is a whole
new magnitude of ridiculous foolishness
what you're doing there is you're trying
to make sense of the inexplicable and
that that's an understandable instinct
it's a normal pursuit right
it is noble and you're also giving them
the benefit of the doubt weirdly
by suggesting that they're maybe being
disingenuous you're saying they can't be
as
maniacal as they seem uh so that's
actually quite a positive thing that
you're doing there
but unfortunately i you know i on the
other hand do like to take people at
face value and i
and i i i believe that people mean what
they say
unless proven otherwise so i'm going to
assume
that they they do believe this and that
is a scarier world
you're in there i mean that is that is
that is a frightening place
although i do notice that in
conversation
such people rarely say things that are
that unhinged they
they tend to reserve them for for
twitter
or you know so i don't know what that
tells us um
uh but i you know i hope you're right i
hope i hope it is just a game
and that they don't seriously believe
what they say
you